I have a million things I want to talk
to you about and I think the first is
probably the most important have you
guys started getting residuals from
Musso and Frankie aha that's a good idea
that I think we should least get a
t-shirt
things been going on no but we've
unfortunately now the word finished our
second year into the second year we're
out of Musso francs and it's a set you
know so now we just now have been
established they just go boom Musso
francs then we're down into the into the
booth is set as otherwise I used to I I
love it yeah I mean I I think they
should be paying you they yeah they're
doing fine right they've landed on their
feet one of the things listen I I think
that shut Lori's writing on this show is
incredible
and what I love is how it doesn't rely
on these cheap gimmicks to move plot
along it's honest conversations between
friends can you sort of talk about
Chuck's dialogue in his work well I'm so
happy you say that you know first of all
I can't believe that Chuck Lorre has
never won an Emmy yeah it's crazy I mean
III don't know quite what he's who he's
pissed off or what but he's just so damn
talented I mean that the script that you
sent it to me and I was the last day I
was that Sabbath the way you have our
comedy I'm television and I read this
this is great writing this is such good
writing I mean you know forget feature
films and this is just really great
writing and he just was never done in a
one camera you know show before
everything was like four cameras and he
wanted to learn himself so there's no
other writer it was like writing in
stable he wrote every day I'm episode
himself I used to ask him and he didn't
know or one episode was gonna go to the
next until he finished it and then the
characters would drive him into wherever
the next one episode would go it was not
like he he Matt most shows they kind of
lay out outlined before begins the arc
of the show and where it's all going to
go and he just sort of you know let it
happen which made for great streaming
watching binge watching because you know
one episode would finish the
next we'll pick up an hour later a day
later so he was you know full flow but
I'm glad you said that I think he I
think he's he's writing a spectacular
the thing that you mentioned it a little
bit but I learned today that I didn't
realize he doesn't know where the next
episode look he's on set watching you
guys work and then he decides okay now I
know what so Drees gonna exactly exactly
that was a big big lesson for him he
also said the thing also you realize is
in for camera shows with the audience
the cameras could never get a close-up
never can get much closer than like
almost waist high or holding two people
you just can't do it he said all of them
on camera
I need close-ups so I realized a lot of
situations I don't have to write that
much because the face the expression
will tell you what's happening more than
my writing said totally adjusted like
the length of his scripts in this second
season I'm curious
I I'm a fan of the show i binge two both
seasons very quickly have you guys had
conversations about doing the third
season we're having conversations yeah
we're having conversations it's it's
there's a lot of a lot of moving parts
you sure I love it I love I'm enjoying
the show and it's it's great I hope all
the moving parts line up together before
you go I gotta tell you that I got a
sure one leaving yep when do I have
another question for you but you tell me
give me your question that's more
important than when I oh I was gonna why
have a two-parter and the first part is
what does it mean to be part of the
biggest box office movie of all time
with Avengers endgame and my other thing
is I'm so excited you're doing in this
thing what if or you're voicing Hank Pym
and like an animated thing am i I heard
I have no idea okay
second person think we came in here I'm
looking at your yeah sure
as far as the one that'll be a little
asterisk which I'll be able to keep by
my name let's just say if you saw the
the biggest grossing picture in the
history
this is you might catch me for the brief
but brief moments in the in the in the
whole cast that's up there but it's
pretty cool I mean it's pretty cool to
marvel world has really been in blast I
love them I'm having a great time we're
starting a third one and beginning in
January 21 is our date for starting
another Marvel and as far as Netflix
well I what I wanted to say was I have
another series that I'm doing for
Netflix isn't wait is it the green green
eggs and ham am I reading exit you know
everything let the kindest thing is come
your company must be amazing in terms of
the information that you have access to
well I did that off the top of my head
but we need sit have yeah that's an
animated I'm doing a part of guy and
Diane Keaton is in it qicang Keys Adam
Adam Devine so that's coming out soon -
so listen sir I'm thank you so much for
giving me your time questions I love
anytime I do it longer what would do
someone by all means